the hint of a smile after two months in
hellish conditions
buses that made their way out of azov
style steel plant friday stopped off for
the night in a village just outside
mariupol
ukraine's azov battalion says one of its
soldiers was killed early friday when
russian forces fired at the evacuation
convoy it's not known how many civilians
remain inside as of style perhaps over a
hundred along with ukrainian troops
their fate for better or worse could be
decided by monday
that's the victory day public holiday in
russia when it's expected vladimir putin
will want something to celebrate the
fighting in ukraine but especially in
mariopol has been turned into this
almost a mini small scale symbolic
victory so mariopol is very important
amnesty international now says it has
gathered evidence that russian troops
committed war crimes in the region north
of kiev we know they are part of a
pattern
that has characterized russia's conduct
of the hostilities from the outset
a repeated pattern large in scale and
devastating in impact russia has denied
targeting civilians on friday its u.n
ambassador called such evidence a
coordinated campaign of lies the reality
however is strong strikingly different
and ukrainian authorities in the western
bankers are not interested in shedding
any light on it of course russia has
also denied this is a war at all
the kremlin is also lashing out at those
who suggested russia might use nuclear
weapons
but twice in recent weeks russian state
tv aired segments describing potential
nuclear attacks against the west
and as victory day approaches one of the
aircraft practicing fly pasts above
moscow is the illusion il-80 russia's
airborne command center for a would-be
nuclear war redmond shannon global news
london